[Music]
[Applause]
welcome to the 2017 Google Play Awards
please welcome
purnima Koscheck our director of apps
and games business development Google
Play good evening and welcome to the
second annual Google Play Awards we
launched this awards last year at i/o to
celebrate your amazing work behind every
great app is a creative vision and a
remarkable team today we celebrate you
your vision and your teams
it's a privilege for us at Google to be
part of your amazing work you build
beautiful apps successful businesses and
touch lives of people around the world
and you challenge us to innovate on our
platforms and keep pace with your
imagination I couldn't be more excited
about the diversity of the nominees in
today's categories from apps that teach
kids to code to ones that allow you to
play with friends around the world from
FinTech to feeding the hungry it is
amazing to see the many different
countries you come from and the many
many different apps that you're building
and as where I stand it is exciting for
me to also see all the wonderful things
that connect you you have a relentless
focus on your users our innovation
hunger to pick up the latest features
and capabilities and a dedication to
build beautiful apps that engage
in looking at your apps the judging
panel of of course took into account
innovation and design but also thought
about things like app quality that
actually lead to user happiness things
like does your app drain battery none of
us like that
do we and judging by the ratings and
reviews on Google Play we assure that
our users and your users agree that your
apps exemplify the best that is there in
Android and play so with no further ado
let's get the show started stand out
Indy please welcome Jamil mol Idina gain
strategic lead Google Play right before
coming to Google I ran an indie game
startup I learned firsthand how risky
innovation is for a small studio but at
the same time innovation may be all you
have to stand out it's then incumbent
upon platforms to shine a spotlight on
those developers that dare to try
something new and helping operate that
spotlight at Google is one way that I've
been able to give back to this rich
diverse community Indies have inherent
value in that they demonstrate the
endless capability of what small teams
can build they pour their hearts and
souls into their work they embody
diversity and often they take unexpected
leap introducing us to unique game
controls and breakthrough story ideas
all stemming from a deep passion for
their art while using games as a medium
to express the human condition this
year's nominees deliver on all town
let's take a look stand out indie
nominees are
causality Kingdom new land
Mars Mars mushroom 11 rain stand out in
D
the winner of this year's award is the
epitome of a beautiful game experience
on mobile it's stunning graphics
melancholic soundtrack and unique and
native game controls give gamers the
perfect immersion into the challenges
and outcomes of this world I fell in
love the first time I played the early
version of this game and I'm thrilled
that we can share it with everyone on
Google Play the winner of this year's
standout indie award is mushroom 11 by
untamed
[Music]
[Applause]
standout startup
please welcome Larisa Fontaine director
and global head of apps business
development Google Play like in these
startups are all about taking risks and
fueling innovation small and scrappy the
most exciting startups inspire all of us
by taking great ideas and turning them
into breakout success stories at play we
care a lot about making sure that start
us to find their audience and that users
can find the greatest and exciting apps
that are coming from this community in
addition to innovating inside their own
app stunts are often early adopters of
new platforms and new technology
features which means they're creating
some of the most interesting Android
experiences today and they're also
becoming from of our best partner so now
that we've set that bar really high
let's take a look at the nominees janda
startup nominees are cat box
[Music]
digit discord hook simple habit stand
out start up this year's winner Felton
built an original experience by
rethinking fiction through the texting
generation they use an everyday mobile
behavior to deliver creative and
captivating stories that immerse the
user in the narrative in real time as a
lifelong bookworm I'm thrilled to
announce that this year's standout
startup Award winner is hooked by
telepathic
[Applause]
[Music]
test Android wear experience please
welcome David singleton VP engineering
[Music]
Android wear enables developers to reach
users with glanceable information
throughout the day and with where to
Touro which is our latest release we
introduced standalone apps these allow
you to build experiences that operate
independently without necessarily
requiring the phone nearby the new apps
being created helps simplify life's
daily activities such as staying
informed exploring what's nearby and
accessing guides and metrics to improve
your personal health and workout
routines and while Android wear is still
a platform in its infancy we are so
excited by the support from both
developers and hardware manufacturers
and I hope more you will try it out
let's take a look at this year's
nominees best Android wear experience
nominees are Springs Foursquare
like some run tactic running and fitness
[Music]
seven best Android wear experience the
winner of this year's award offers a
smart and sleek experience utilizing the
convenience of GPS and other key sensors
this year's winner of best Android wear
experience is runtastic running in
fitness
[Applause]
[Music]
that TV experience
please welcome Sascha pruder director
Android TV I really need a new stock
photo so while many mobile developers
build for the small screens such as
Android we're just presented this
category celebrates those who reach
audiences through Android TV and take
advantages and advantage of the largest
screen in the house building for the
large screen allows developers to
explore new menu and UI options to
create rich media media experiences that
drive real long session time and thanks
to a strong developer community so
thanks to you the TV app section is fast
growing and a successful category the
number of TV apps in the Play Store on
Android TV have doubled since Google i/o
last year and it's now exceeding 3000
apps and games so let's take a look at
the nominees for this year's best TV
experience best TV experience nominees
are a Baima TV haystack TV
kkbox Netflix Red Bull TV best TV
experience this year's winner has
completely updated you I try to refresh
best-in-class TV user experience using
simple controls and beautiful designs
they give users a Content rich offering
with high quality live and on-demand
content the winner of this year's best
TV experience is red bull TV by Red Bull
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Applause]
[Music]
best VR experience
please welcome clay before VP virtual
reality so VR is cool because it can
like that guy really make you feel like
you're somewhere else whether you're on
a beach with scary crab zombies or
searching an ancient shipwreck for VR
treasure it really puts you right in the
action and you don't just get to see
what it's like to be somewhere else but
really experience it so daydream is our
platform for mobile virtual reality and
thanks to the passion and creativity of
some amazing developers there's a large
and growing library of really cool
things to experience and do you can
explore different worlds you can step
inside games and you can just kick back
and watch your own personal cinema we've
been so impressed with what we've seen
so far and so it's my huge pleasure to
announce the nominees for best VR
experience that VR experience nominees
are
the arc slinger gun Jack - end of shift
Mecca Rama V are the turning forest
[Music]
virtual virtual reality best VR
experience I love them all it but the
winner it's hard to describe the kind of
crazy off-the-wall experience of
exploring 50 50 different alternate
realities doing weird jobs for bored
artificial intelligences all while
trying to uncover the backstory of the
kind of shady company activity the
virtual labor system of the future so
you just have to try it the winner of
this year's best VR experience is
virtual virtual reality by Tenderfoot
[Music]
[Applause]
you best AR experience
please welcome Amite Singh VP of
business and operations Villar hello
everybody
just like clay was talking about what
your reality can take you anywhere
augmented reality AR can bring anything
to you as if it was there and we've been
working on a project for a while called
tango it allows phones to sense just
like we do gap scale perception
precision it can really bring objects as
if they were right there and people have
done amazing things with it you can shop
for a couch make sure it fits the
environment you're in or you can invite
dinosaurs and play with them in your
kitchen and so let's take a look at the
nominees who build these amazing AR
experiences powered by tango that AR
experienced nominees are
Crayola Color Blaster dinosaurs among us
Paolo Wayfarer view world best AR
experience very very tough choice these
are all great you must try and try them
out they're all actually in the in the
pod over there with the daydream and
dangled experience the one that is the
winner really brings whimsical fanciness
lets you like be in your space and
decorate the world and it's just fun it
hard to describe but super fun to play
and the winner is world by phenomenon
[Applause]
you
[Music]
sex apps for kids
please welcome Shazia mok do me global
head of education and Family Partnership
Google Play
hi everyone so as the mom of two boys
for age nine and ten and was captivated
by worlds of Harry Potter and minecraft
I love how great apps and games can
capture kids imagination and fire their
creativity but in addition the right
apps also go beyond that they helped
change parents perceptions of mobile
devices beyond electronic babysitters to
tools that help their kids develop
skills to explore to thrive and to learn
now if only someone could build an app
that gives my kids that same age forever
however developers in a design for
families programs while they don't do
that
they use intuitive and kid-friendly
design together with age-appropriate
content to engage and inspire kids with
colorful characters creative visuals
realistic sounds they build fun
educational and safe experiences on
mobile devices so this year's nominees I
offer diverse lineup show to appeal to
any household with kids
let's take a look best app for kids
nominees are animaljam
play wild
Hot Wheels race off Keaney Titan
[Music]
thang-thang toca life vacation best apps
for kids so just like it's really hard
as any parent would know to pick your
favorite child you know we've had to
make a choice here so love them all but
can you imagine anything more fun than
showing off your style with characters
that express the real you this year's
winner teaches kids how to use their
creativity to build explore and share
all while learning about science the
winner of this year's best app for kids
is Animal Jam play wire
[Applause]
[Music]
best multiplayer game please welcome
Jason Titus VP of engineering developer
product group so one of the one of the
greatest things about mobile phones is
how they let us play together across
continents and take time whether it's a
line or on the bus and actually make it
a time playing with their friends in
recent years we've seen amazing
improvement with multiplayer games
taking advantage of the huge numbers of
mobile users as well as the advanced
technology and today's phones
multiplayer games come in all genres and
sizes but the thing that they have in
common is their amazing ability to bring
us together a true multiplayer game is
built from the ground up and this year's
nominees are some of the best let's take
a look best multiplayer games nominees
are dawn of Titan
[Music]
FIFA mobile hearthstone Lord mobile
modern strike online best multiplayer
game this year's winner reaches a global
audience of nearly 190 countries it's
developed by a team of 30 different
nationalities which seems so appropriate
through the developers continual push
for excellence through iteration and
experimentation this app is constantly
evolving to make learning one of your
favorite leisure activities sorry make
learning whether your favorite leisure
activities the winner of this year's
best multiplayer game is hearthstone
from Blizzard Entertainment
[Music]
[Applause]
best app watching you please welcome
Jamie Rosenberg VP Android and play
business hi everyone it's great to have
all of you here it's amazing to think
about the innovation in mobile apps over
the past few years we've seen so many
great examples of that already tonight
as smartphones have become more powerful
you all have kept pace by finding more
ways for our phones to help us in our
daily lives great apps help us create
explore stay fit organize learn and so
much more the very best of these do so
through excellence in design and
performance thoughtful use of the
capabilities of our devices and often a
bit of fun let's take a look at the
nominees for best app best ass nominees
are City members fabulous
[Music]
memorize money lover quick best app so
I'm just going to cut to the chase this
app takes an activity that can be a drag
and makes it a ton of fun the Google
Play award for best app goes to memorize
[Applause]
[Music]
that game please welcome
Samir cemaat VP play and Android
[Music]
I've been playing games on smartphones
for a very long time and I think we can
all agree that games have come a long
way on mobile it's exciting to see so
many of you using the capabilities of
the platform to build amazing
experiences you're helping to change the
way people think about mobile gaming by
presenting rich storylines mind-blowing
graphics and bringing out the competitor
in each of us with two billion Android
devices developers have the freedom to
build fun and engaging experiences
knowing that an audience is just one tap
away let's take a look at this year's
nominees that games nominees are choices
Fire Emblem hero lineage to revolution
[Music]
Pokemon go Transformers Forge to fight
best game
now all these titles are inspiring this
year's winner brings console quality
graphics to mobile showcasing gaming on
Android through stunning 3d graphics and
incredible technical performance
they're bringing iconic characters to
life and offering an inspiration for
what gaming can truly be on mobile the
winner of this year's best game award is
transformers towards the fight
you
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh
that's accessibility experience
please welcome Hiroshi Locke himer SVP
platforms and ecosystems how's everyone
doing having fun okay before before we
get to this I just want to say a quick
thank you you know Android Google Play
we would be nowhere without you so a big
thank you to the developer community
thank you very much
all right well I've Google our mission
is to organize the world's information
and make it universally accessible and
useful universally accessible so with
this mission in mind and that phrase in
mind it's with great pleasure that I got
to introduce this new category best
accessibility experience here we will
fight highlight developers that offer
innovative solutions to assist users
with different accessibility needs and
overcoming common challenges they
deliver intuitive experiences empower
individuals through mobile apps they
foster communication build independence
and have the capability of connecting
users in very meaningful ways so let's
take a look at the nominees best
acceptability experience nominees are a
blind legend ID if
[Music]
Open Sesame
twitch key symbols best accessibility
experience all right well the winner of
this year's award is a brilliantly
designed platform offering experience
inclusive for users and developers with
various needs they simplify daily tasks
especially for those with vision and
motor impairments to increase
productivity and independence please
join me in congratulating at this year's
winner of this best Excel accessibility
experience if
[Applause]
[Music]
best social impact it's me again I'm
back you know I was hoping from a
headshot again but you'll get it live
instead okay so developer ecosystem has
an extremely diverse makeup the product
of this breath of culture personal
interest and creative vision produces a
lot of truly amazing work you make a lot
of amazing work thank you this category
looks for apps that create meaningful
social impact for a broad spectrum of
people around the world while taking
full advantage of the platform it
rewards developers who challenge
themselves to promote themes of
contribution accessibility and knowledge
sharing through creative solutions that
address issues locally regionally and
even globally so let's take a look at
the nominees best social impact nominees
are charity miles peak acuity
pro-death see HeroQuest
[Music]
share the meal best social impact this
year's winner generates large-scale
reach to fight a major global issue the
app uses a simple interface to drive
awareness and engagement of a major
cause there are a tremendous partner and
I encourage you all to try out their new
instant app launching here at IO the
winner of this year's best social impact
award is share the meal
[Applause]
[Music]
please welcome back purnima Kochi car
[Applause]
what an amazing lineup isn't it one more
time give a big hand to all the nominees
and the winners
[Applause]
I echo Hiroshima and he said without you
our tools and our platforms are nothing
so we thank you for your commitment for
your innovation and I can't wait to see
you here next year to see what you would
have built between now and then so thank
you all for coming I hope you enjoy the
rest of the show there's a big show at
the amphitheater at 8 o'clock we hope to
see you there thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]